l'explosion a dû ouvrir une brèche dans
la coque
je suis à la dérive sans puissance était
contrôlé je dirais complètement la
veille est ce que quelqu'un me reçoit
moi je vous entends tu toi qui parle à
tort d'essayer de comptes en vous
sentant qui êtes-vous
moi je vous dis que c'est aucune
coordonnée
d'accord mais j'ai pas la moindre
coordonnées l'espace ça vous parle
combien
je veux que vous appliquez chez moi faut
qu'elle sache que je suis désolé le
hublot de l'acacia
[Musique]
ça va pas fonctionner j'arriverai
pourquoi profite cette capsule n'a pas
de sas notre enfer les propulseurs sont
en rade donc c'est mission impossible
je sais que tout ce qui compte pour eux
à l'heure qu'il est c'est l'argent de la
police
je suis déjà mort
focalisé matignon dès maintenant